oh here's uh here's is that his daughter
oh no that's his son and that one I
believe is Eric I know I think that's
Don jr. Eric's the other one Eric's the
one who looks like a prairie dog with
blonde hair
there's a stood up prairie dog yes when
he's sort of like danger you know his
daughter with her husband who is who is
up and put in charge of the the Middle
East peace process which is a great
thing to do if someone spent their life
as a hedge fund manager I think the best
thing to do is to put them in charge of
the most volatile I think there's no
need to attack landscapers David Oban
there's behringer bears up same energy
he's always a very bubbly child
no I fear what does it come it was so
much you've come into my inauguration
Baron I predict he's one of those kids
who who goes crazy and eat someone's
face really interesting that's all baby
yeah there's not enough of us
there's his daughter who he my
understanding is dog chomp would like to
have sex with her I don't think that's
what he wants to have sex with that's
not the one that's not Ivanka no he does
want to bang Ivanka but I don't think he
said anything about yeah Tiffany that's
not Ivanka no and that is a little
racist not all pretty blonde women look
alike Dave I think the best ride she's
practiced that walk yeah she's
practicing her whole life Ivanka studied
walking most of her childhood it's nice
to see also Don jr. is sort of starting
to form the Trump chortle - so you do
know that that is they are you know a
lot of people think this family might be
invented you can tell right there
genetics is a big player Ivanka is an
absolute angel
she is today she looks like she's
running some sort of space council that
will decide Superman's fate rare shot of
Baron smiling oh we missed it
oh sorry I was talking over that that's
like a Halley's Comet moment it's got
great hair I really as dad actually
takes some of his hair I believe that is
a part some people think that's the
reason why white Baron was bred but yeah
there's
that's ridiculous I did a hair farm yeah
I I understand it being told there is a
little bit of a delay because Trump is
pissing on a woman